cyberpunk 2077 is getting a sequel more
Witcher games than you can shake a stick
at Dead Space reveals final gameplay and
a Nintendo Direct is coming this week
all on today's Gamespot news
as part of its strategy presentation CD
projekt Red has announced that it has
multiple new games in development
although details are slim the company
did announce that a sequel to 2020
cyberpunk 2077 is in development under
the codename project Orion and will
quote prove the full power and potential
of the cyberpunk universe when it is
released additionally a number of new
games set in The Witcher Universe are
also in various stages of development
these are all being developed under
various code names as well and include
project Sirius project Polaris and
project Canis Majoris for project Sirius
this Witcher game is described as an
Innovative take on the series that is
aimed at both veteran fans and people
new to the franchise currently in
pre-production it is being developed by
Flame in the flood developer the
Molasses Flood and has 60 plus people
involved in its creation project Polaris
is described as a story-driven open
world RPG built on the legacy of The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt and has more than
150 people working on it at CD project
red this game will be the start of a new
Witcher Trilogy that is aimed to be
delivered within a six-year period
following the Polaris release a
story-driven single-player open world
RPG set within the witch Universe
project Canis Majoris will be developed
by a third-party Studio that will be led
by ex-witcher veterans Beyond its two
most well-known franchises CD projekt
Red is also working on a new Standalone
IP codename project are it has been in
quote IP incubation since 2021 and is
currently in the conceptual phase this
game is described as being distinct from
cyberpunk 2077 and The Witcher and is
being developed 100 internally
a game that is releasing much sooner
than any of CD projekt's Red's
announcements is the remake of Dead
Space which got a first look at
finalized gameplay today following the
story of the original game the trailer
shows engineer Isaac Clarke aboard the
spaceship ishimura having traveled there
with his crew in response to a distress
signal and distress is putting it
lightly the trailer shows off gnarly
gameplay of Isaac hacking through the
former crew of the ship which have been
mutated by a mysterious Relic all with
his engineering tools such as his iconic
plasma cutter you can take control of
Isaac and confront these alien
Abominations yourself when the game
releases on January 27 2023
[Music]
speaking of Abominations you're going to
get to hear Chris Pratt's Mario voice
very soon Nintendo has announced the
next Nintendo Direct for this Thursday
October 6th and it will be focused on
the Super Mario Bros movie the first
trailer for the movie will make its
debut and presumably the broadcast will
include other news and updates around
the film there will be no game
announcements however the event begins
at 1 to 5 PM Pacific Time or 4 or 5 PM
Eastern Time the movie is produced by
illumination the studio behind minions
and Despicable Me it is directed by
Aaron Horvath and Michael yellenik who
previously collaborated on the animated
Teen Titans Go films The Lego Movie 2
and minions the rise of Gru writer
Matthew Fogle wrote the script for the
movie which is produced by Mario creator
Shigeru Miyamoto and illuminations Chris
melodandri Nintendo's tweet includes
what appears to be a first look at the
the Mario movies art style a poster
image seems to suggest that Mario will
embark on an epic adventure to reach the
mushroom Castle in addition to Chris
Pratt as the voice of Mario the movie
features an All-Star cast that includes
Anya Taylor joya's Peach Charlie day is
Luigi Jack Black as Bowser Keegan
Michael key is Toad Seth Rogen as Donkey
Kong Fred Armisen as Cranky Kong Kevin
Michael Richardson's comic and Sebastian
Maniscalco as Spike the Mario movie was
originally lined up for release in
December this year before it was delayed
to April 7 2023 pratta said his Mario
voices quote unlike anything you've ever
heard and I bet that that is the case
and that is it for today's Gamespot news
which CD project red title excites you
the most are you excited to see your
first look at the Super Mario Bros movie
let us know in the comments below and
we'll see you here tomorrow for more
Gamespot news